[Musique]
paul bergeron aura passé trente quatre
ans à l'inspection des aliments à santé
canada
pas du genre à se tourner les pouces à
la retraite il ya dix ans il décide de
s'impliquer au journal de rue
l'itinéraire en cuisinant des repas pour
les camelots les camelots souvent c'est
des gens qui viennent de la rue si on
veut être 60 et on veut aussi qu'ils ne
commencent pas manger n'importe quoi
n'importe où pour venir à bout de faire
ses menus équilibrés
monsieur paul comme on l'appelle
affectueusement met ses connaissances à
profit
j'ai pas la connaissance de l'ithq point
de vue d'apprêter allemagne façon avec
une sorte d'apparence et soit de cuisson
là mais j'ai la connaissance de l'animal
donc je pense et une bonne connaissance
surtout comme on a des aliments en fin
de vie faux faut se dépêcher à les
utiliser ou à les préparer pour pouvoir
les conserver
avant d'arriver dans la cuisine de
monsieur paul c'est poivrons ont d'abord
été choisi par pierre tuga lors de ses
visites hebdomadaires chez moisson
montréal une banque alimentaire qui
récupère des dons de nourriture pour les
distribuer à des organismes
communautaires avec quelques-uns le
terreau aura besoin d'être nettoyé mais
ce encore comestibles
c'est lui qui fait des courses pour le
café l'itinéraire look fait choisir ce
que vous glissez elles sont en très
bonne état même jaurès à lipsky
s'approvisionner en fait vous en dis que
sont offerts par moisson montréal donc j
avec un camion et un chauffard ont fait
le plein de scarpi de ce qu'on nous
parce que c'est ce que c'est jallet va
voir plein de choses que ne pas en avoir
moins et par une grande variété comme il
peut en avoir moins ce n'est pas tout
vous d ali belhaj a pâti du beurre
j'en ai pris sauf que là il voulait sent
bien que le plus hot seat intra-uem
parce que je voulais avoir refoulé un
par un boeuf et un poids sauf si là
c'est toujours comme ça on ne savait pas
ce qu'il va y avoir avant d'arriver là
jamais
on met le tout dans le camion puis ces
directions l'itinéraire où les produits
sont emmenés dans la cuisine de monsieur
paul
on est comme la personne qui est là
quand vos parents et sont partis en
vacances pendant une semaine puis qui
vous ont de suite notre frigo on a
rempli le frigo pitt deux doigts de nour
et tout le monde durant la semaine
alors ça ça veut dire que le lundi on
ouvre le frigo qu'est-ce qu'on me lada
soixante quinze repas par jour 375 par
semaine monsieur paul n'a pas le choix
dans sa cuisine tout se transforme et
surtout rien ne se perd que l'on va
regarder comment nombreux traités là aux
retraités est très bon le reste on
enlève ça c'est très bon pour les très
bons le fort bien alors pour pas gêné
pour un vélib parti pis on les enlève
on n'est pas obligé de dire à toute la
famille j'ai enlevé cette partie là
restée très bon bain contenant de dire
ça on allait ma mère est est ce qu'ils
savent pas ça fait pas mal a donc on va
les découper on voit enlever que c'est
pas bon ont voulu faire blanchir avant
peut-être de les conserver en prison oui
congélateur c'est le poids de son beau
alors un très beau départ au centre et
vaud et pour les légumes qui iront au
frigo l'ancien inspecteur des aliments a
plus d'un tour dans son sac
quand on voit des mutliples dans notre
ca ou quand on voit des gouttelettes sur
le couvert de notre contenu samedi que
dans notre continent
on a à peine 100 % d'humidité à eau de
85% les mots sur les bactéries sont bien
contentes
alors on va on veut pour sa dépense 85%
home and gaming qui elle va absorber le
surplus de mystique
ça vaut pour tous les légumes parce que
tous les règlements racines le nicaragua
le pas mais tous ces choses là ouais
c'est bon parce que ça concerne le
ministère légumes et ça empêche
l'excellent vise qui
[Musique]
par votre épicerie et livrer des gens
vous vous êtes en mode de création qui
se voit pas et quand même dit ongles
d'autres wagons pas vous partiriez avec
quoi la première recette note que vous
pourriez faire avec ce que vous avez
reçu aujourd'hui comme on veut pas
traiter de légumes et comme ont eu
beaucoup de temps ça adonne bien on fait
des cretons maintenant on n'en sait
guère plus pour déjeuner nous on fait
des sales ou chaud creton parce que les
gens ils viennent prendre la soupe on
leur fait sans doute à côté semaine
quand on s'est fait juste avec la viande
de porc mais selon on avait un
arrangement au boeuf beau donc on
retourne ça pourrait très bon en fait ça
c'est de la viande nature tient mais on
peut mettre ce maquereau thon
on s'adapte on fait dire une différence
pourquoi avant parce qu'on a ce que nous
en cuisine comme une cuisine familiale
donc ça faisait qu' on n'est pas à
reproduire de vaud la même chose
une façon identique comme le cuisinier
d'un grand restaurant lui doit reprendre
reprendre la même recette avec les mêmes
goûts mais les mêmes apparente
aujourd'hui rien de bien compliqué il y
aura suffisamment de creton pour faire
une cinquantaine de sandwichs sont bien
nous rêvons camelot en jeu soit bien
nourrie c'est ça aussi des fois quand on
fait des plats cuisinés on nous dit
qu'on vient à mettre la dame ne peut se
passer parce qu'on veut que ce soit bon
qui mange bien ça passe un test en scène
voilà le tamini ça va assez bien depuis
tant qu en face aux sabres ont fini par
ses bons conseils
son expertise son dévouement les
qualités qui font de monsieur paul un
pilier de l'itinéraire leur avait décidé
de tirer votre révérence
ouais parce que là j'ai soixante et dix
ans alors dix ans de bénévolat play et à
settat dans mon programme de vie j'ai
tout accompli et bien fait sans
d'ailleurs si c'est pas juste faire mais
c'est bien faire c'est dans la cuisine
aussi c'est ce qu'on fait on essaie de
faire les choses et de bien les femmes
wolof vaut tirer ma révérence parce que
en même temps ça va donner de l'énergie
nouvelle va arriver à l'itinéraire
sûrement quelqu'un quoi pour apprendre
la cuisine avec des idées nouvelles de
notre nouvelle carte raid
merci beaucoup monsieur paul ce que
j'avais fait l'itinéraire en fait
plaisir bonne chance à rennes chance à
vous